foreign
question of the day comes from Jonathan
in the Netherlands he says we really
don't feel the necessity or the urgency
to follow the beans and rice style of
baby step two I can imagine that it
might feel nice to have no debt and we
have no intention of getting further
into debt however I don't feel it's
worth living on rice and beans for three
years to pay off forty three thousand
dollars of student loans as soon as
possible as we're young we're a young
family we're making sixty five hundred
dollars a month and now we can use our
income and savings to buy a second hand
bigger car make a garden make our garden
a bit nicer and later in life we'll have
more to spare to pay off those loans
anyway what are your thoughts on this
and would it be uh what would be the
benefit of still following the baby
steps more rigidly that's a really good
question and you know what Dave I hear
this a lot I think a lot of people are
like why do I have to be so urgent why
do I have to be so intense and I look at
it a couple of different ways
um number one the series of steps that
we follow
um this is a guy you know Jonathan I
don't mean any harm but you're kind of
just an ish guy right you're doing what
you want to do you're really not on our
plan and that's fine you don't have to
be it's your prerogative but the way the
steps work is you're doing them
consecutively and the first three to
three you're doing them with intensity
so that you can get to the final four
which is really that wealth building
area so there's
um some method to this madness but this
kind of goes back to what we've talked
about before
um
there is urgency because
how many I mean I think about my
grandmother who would say you know if
you want to make God laugh tell them
your plans and there is something to be
said for that I think a lot of people
just Coast through because they think
hey you know this is my plan if I just
go out like this it's gonna go you know
check off the boxes like that but you
really don't know what's going to come
your way you know God willing everything
goes fine and you know you you'll keep
that income and everything will be
perfect and everybody's healthy and
every but you don't know that and I
think that you've got to live each day
to the fullest you got to do the best
that you can with each day that you're
given and when you've got debt pay it
off you got forty three thousand dollars
of debt and you make a fine income it
doesn't have to take you three years to
pay this off you could honestly pay it
off a lot faster than that and at the
end of the day it Jonathan what you're
trying to say is your plan sucks it
sucks it sucks because it's not gonna
work
people have been trying to do the crap
you're talking about
for 50 years
and it doesn't work
you can't sort of kind of get out of
debt and ever get out of debt it doesn't
work it's just actual that you can't
find any proof text in the marketplace
of someone who wanders along and Lolly
gags and sticks with it and gets out in
10 years but plants his little garden
well give me a break call the wambulance
you know seriously this is ridiculous
this is just somebody who doesn't want
to sacrifice to win well period but
you're not going to win okay because
there's no middle ground with this
really now I've been doing this a long
time it's not just that you're not doing
our stuff so please do not follow the
baby steps please do not tell people
you're doing Ramsay no he's not doing it
because I don't want to be insulted by
your abject failure
and I don't want my brand damaged by it
okay just because it's not going to work
here's the reason Jonathan all right the
thing works like this
if you don't really with great intensity
focus on a dramatic change in Behavior
where you have been going in the wrong
direction
you will never change the behavior
we're not asking you to live on beans
and rice the rest of your life
or to or even okay you're gonna cave and
collect lint and only come out on Triple
Coop on Thursday but what you're doing
will not actually work because it's not
sustainable because it has absolutely no
energy
I just think I'm gonna kind of wander
I'm gonna get a nice house and it's all
going to work out no it's not Jonathan
no it's not because you're gonna get
your freaking head taken off by life and
you're going to look up 15 16 years into
your little marriage and go Dad come we
are stupid people we are still treading
water and ask all these people that are
45 and 50 years old that tried to wander
out and then they found us and in 36
months they got out of debt and they do
their debt free scream they'll tell you
they'll tell you your little plan sucks
because it does it won't work is why it
sucks and when you're lukewarm like that
you say I have no intentions of getting
back into debt yeah you will yeah you
will you definitely will because you're
not committed to the idea the the idea
of where debt Freedom will take you
which is into wealth and into a whole
nother realm of generosity then you
could even grasp right now is not
appealing to you as much as your garden
give me a break
seriously will not work Jonathan will
not work so you can go do what you want
to do but please do not associate my
name with it because I don't want to be
tied to your failure and you go I tried
that Ramsey stuff and it doesn't work no
you didn't
no you didn't because we know that
there's a high probability you are never
going to get out of debt unless you
attack it like your dad gum life depends
on it you got to get so fired up and
wired up that your character shifts your
neuro plasticity moves and the way your
brain works where when you see debt you
recoil when you pull up next to a nice
car at a traffic light you now no longer
go oh that's a nice car you go that
fool's got payments yeah well you know
he right now he's stuck in Comfort his
life he feels comfortable he says I
don't think there's any need to get
uncomfortable to change this I'm cushy
the greatest thing to get greatest enemy
of Excellence is not bad things the
greatest enemy of Excellence is the okay
yep just fine I'm okay it's just fine
I'm okay that's so true Dave no you're
not you suck you're not okay
your plan sucks yeah it's it's pitiful
and it's not going to work debt is like
riding a motorcycle it's not if you
crash it's when you crash because you
will crash remember that
oh
why don't you go against motorcycles I'm
just saying it's not if it's when George
Georgian horses shooting motorcycles
you won't get me on a bike if you crash
but when you crash that's dead they call
them
coma mobiles or something oh gosh that's
even worse than what I said dude
my wife told me I could have a
motorcycle but she wouldn't be there so
there you go that's how that works you
and Sharon you and Sharon we I think we
have a lot in common me and Sharon yeah
no doubt about that